good morning
happy Sabbath
it's a good day isn't it well I'd love
to be with on fire Adventist young
people
amen
boy that was that was slow now I
expected that from the guys that are
more my age they're going to be saying
well wait a minute should I say Amen to
that but
I am really glad to be here I want to
tell you a little bit uh just a very
little about myself to get into the
topic this morning uh first I want to
express my thanks to Advent hope for
asking me to come here and speak uh
we're going to be talking about the
spirit of Prophecy which is what our
quarterly is about
um
I grew up in the Adventist Church and my
mother and father were divorced when I
was young and when my mom remarried she
and my stepfather who I lived with
right around 1979 1980 started getting
involved in the teachings of a gentleman
by the name of Desmond Ford
in about 1981 my mother and father
stepfather I should say left the
Adventist Church and me with them and so
uh I lived like a heathen till I was
about 26 years old when I began having
an interest in spiritual things maybe
I'll speak a little bit more about that
this afternoon
but I can tell you that um
one of the big questions I had when I
came back to church was regarding the
spirit of Prophecy the gift of Prophecy
Ellen White's role in our church for
those of you who aren't familiar with
Desmond Ford's Ministry he had two major
points of attack and that was the role
of Ellen White and the teaching of the
sanctuary and so I had a great burden to
understand from the scripture why I
should believe in these things and
that's a lot of what I'm going to be
sharing with you this morning and this
afternoon
um you know one of the young people set
up here leading out the music this
morning let's uh you know act like Jesus
is coming soon let me tell you my
friends he is coming soon one of the
signs of that is the fact that I have to
stand here and speak to Seventh-day
Adventist about the role of the spirit
of Prophecy in the Adventist Church
that's a sign of the end I mean we we
have gotten as a church very far away
from Biblical foundations
and I believe personally and I'm going
to expound on this this morning that if
we had a better understanding of what
the Bible teaches about prophets and
prophecy we wouldn't have these
questions
but much of our Religion Today comes
more from t-shirts and and lyrics of
songs than from the scripture and and
that's Christianity you know in general
and and in fact that maybe I should tell
you this I'm quoting that from a Baptist
preacher I just heard on YouTube in a
sermon like somebody sent me I mean it's
not just the Adventist Christianity in
North America is getting away from the
Bible so we're it says preach the word
here right
is that okay this morning all right so
that's what we're going to do and a lot
of people think well you preach the word
and then when you start talking about
Ellen White then you get outside the
word and talk about Ellen White no no no
no no
we we gain our understanding about
prophets and Prophecy from what the
Bible says just like anything else so
that's what I'm going to attempt to do
this morning is share with you
um
what the scripture says for God's last
day church about the role of prophets
and prophecy and and all that good stuff
now before I go any further I want to
kneel and ask God's special blessing on
this service and I'm going to ask if
you'd bow your heads with me please
Heavenly Father
we thank you for inviting us into your
presence on this sabbath day
and in the words of Moses father show us
your glory
let us see your glory as we open your
word and study today
father give us understanding we pray
that you would send the Holy Spirit to
give understanding on the inspiration
that the Holy Spirit gave
May the holy spirit that inspired the
word that inspired the prophets
illuminate our hearts and Minds today
that we may understand more of this
precious gift to your church
and we ask and pray this in the name of
Jesus and for his sake amen
I'm going to start out with uh a couple
paragraphs that I pull off of Wikipedia
actually looked under uh
the inspiration of Ellen White I think
was the heading
and this is how the first two paragraphs
go it says seven-day Adventists believe
Church co-founder Ellen G white was
inspired by God as a prophet
understood today as a manifestation of
the New Testament spiritual gift of
Prophecy
her inspiration
is considered authoritative yet not
infallible by Church Scholars today
her works are officially considered to
hold a secondary role to the Bible but
in practice there is a wide variation
among Adventists as to exactly how much
Authority should be attributed to her
writings
now maybe I could say it this way there
is a wide variation among Seventh-Day
Adventists about just about everything
and what I'm going to cover this morning
is how the Bible teaches that God gave
the gift of Prophecy to bring us to the
unity of the faith and if we were to
allow it to have its proper place there
would be a Unity instead of all these
variations
okay that's always been the role of the
gift now
it goes on to say with instructions she
claimed was received in Vision White
made administrative decisions gave
personal messages of encouragement or
rebuke to church members and played a
major role in doctrinal development
the debate concerning the validity of
her prophetic gift has been heeded both
from within and outside of the Adventist
Church this debate reached a climax in
the 70s and 80s and since then the
church's position has modified somewhat
to place greater emphasis on her
Humanity infallibility now we're going
to talk about that a little bit this
afternoon in fact I've changed the order
of things this afternoon at 3 P.M we're
going to talk about Ellen White's
plastic surgeons there's been an attempt
to give Ellen White a facelift
and we want to find out how far the
Bible allows for some of the
cosmetic surgery that's going on there
and then at 4 pm the title is she said
she said and I think any Adventist who's
been an Adventist for any period of time
has heard Ellen White said this and
Ellen White said that how are we to take
those things how are we to share what
Ellen White said how are we to
understand the things that Ellen White
said and the Sabbath school lesson this
morning touched on some of that those
are things we're going to be covering
but there has been a greater emphasis on
her humanity and fallibility it says
non-adventists typically believe she was
not uh she was not a prophet although a
few are open to the possibility Walter
Martin who wrote the kingdom of the
Cults and and uh was uh one of the
antagonists of of the Adventist Faith
saw her as a genuine Christian although
not a prophet
others are more critical viewing her as
an unchristian Deceiver
criticisms include her literary
borrowing from other writers some of her
doctrinal positions taken and her
alleged prominence in the church
the Lord permitting we're going to cover
these things today
the first thing I want to start out with
is uh
the the issue of the role of the Prophet
what the Bible says about the role of
the Prophet not Ellen White per se I
mean that's going to fall into this but
what the Bible says about the role of
the prophet in the Christian church some
of you have heard my presentations on
this in fact I've presented these things
at the arrive school for the last
several years in about 18 sessions gyc
asked me to do it in about six sessions
and here it's three
so I'm going to talk really really fast
and then you can get the audioverse
stuff and slow it down and catch
everything no I'm not going to cover
everything I'm going to hope to cover
the the high points uh this morning but
some of this is going to be review from
the Sabbath School quarterly and and
from if you've heard the presentations
before but that's okay repetition
deepens impression right so let's take
our Bibles and let's ask ourselves very
uh first and foremost what a profit is
according to the scripture we're going
to go to the Book of Exodus chapter 4.
and if you were to ask most people even
some Adventists to what a prophet is
most people when they think prophets and
prophecy think future
they tell the future they're they're
they're they're they're prognosticators
but we're going to see what the Bible
says in Exodus chapter four we're going
to look at a couple passages here Exodus
chapter four and uh we're going to go to
verse 10.
God calls Moses to lead his people and
in Exodus 4 verse 10 the Bible says
Moses said to the Lord O Lord I'm not
eloquent neither before nor since you
have spoken to your servant but I am
slow of speech and slow of tongue have
you ever said that when God's called you
to do something Lord I'm not up I can't
tell anybody I can't witness have you
anybody ever do that before
nobody like you just don't oh okay good
good I've done that before and so notice
the Lord's answer verse 11 so the Lord
said to him who has made man's mouth or
who makes the mute the deaf the seeing
or the blind have not I the Lord
now therefore go and I will be with your
mouth and teach you what you shall say
you know God says the same thing to you
and me doesn't he he says go and we say
uh I can't what am I going to say God
says look who made your mouth I made
your mouth I'll tell you what I'll give
you I'll put the words in your mouth
when you need them
thank you but Moses goes on he still
hesitates
and and I relate to this quite a bit he
said but but he said verse 13 oh Lord
please send by the hand of anyone else
you may send have you ever said that
Lord just send somebody else surely you
have somebody else you can send to be a
witness to my family members and my
co-workers or whoever else
verse 14 so the anger of the Lord was
kindled against Moses and he said is it
not Aaron the levite your brother I know
he can speak well and look he's coming
down to meet you when he sees you he'll
be glad in his heart now you shall speak
to him and put the what
put the words where in his mouth and I
will be with your mouth and with his
mouth and I will teach you what you
shall do verse 16. so he shall be your
what
spokesman to the people and he himself
shall be as a mouth for you and you
shall be to him as
God now go to Exodus 7 with me
God said that he was going to make Aaron
what
spokesman notice uh Exodus 7 and verse
1.
Exodus 7 verse 1.
so the Lord said to Moses see I have
made you as God to pharaoh and Aaron
your brother shall be your
Prophet what is a prophet biblically
spokesperson does a prophet necessarily
tell the future Was Elijah a prophet
how much future prophecy did he give
a little bit three and a half years he
in fact he didn't even give the time
period he just said there's not going to
be do or rain until I come back right
what about John the Baptist how much
future did he talk about no he was a
spokesperson for the Lord God gave the
prophet the message the prophet gives
the message to the people
okay you follow that
uh go with me to Revelation chapter one
and we'll see this in action
we find the hierarchy of God's
communication here in Revelation chapter
one
Revelation 1
verse 1.
the Bible says the revelation of Jesus
Christ which God gave him God gave who
Jesus Christ to show his servants things
which must shortly take place and he God
sent and signified it by his Angel to
his servant
John so here's how the Bible says the
prophetic gift Works God reveals to his
son Jesus Jesus then gives the message
to his Angel who gives it to the prophet
who gives it to the servants the people
are you with me so far
so I want you to grasp this I did not
have the vision of Revelation did you
how do I know what John saw
how do I know what God told John did God
tell me no did God tell you
only through the prophet John
now I could get mad and throw a fit
because God only showed John the vision
and say I'm not going to believe it
until you show me the same vision you
showed John
how long do you think I'm going to wait
for that to come come to pass
I it's not up to me to dictate how God
is to communicate to me
isn't that right if God listened
carefully if God wants to communicate to
you through your brother or sister
you need to listen
if God wants to communicate to you
through a husband or wife
you need to listen isn't that right I I
I don't want to hear it from my wife God
you need to tell me some other way no
God's going to tell you how God sees fit
to tell you right and if God wants to
communicate to you or me through a
prophet that's God's prerogative
in what the scripture tells us is that
God communicates through the prophet
that he's chosen prophets to be his
spokespeople and then the prophet in
turn communicates to the Saints
the servants
that's what we see in Revelation 1 and
incidentally that's what we see in the
whole scripture
the bulk of the scripture was written by
prophets things that you wouldn't know
things that I wouldn't know unless a
prophet had them revealed and wrote them
down for you and me isn't that right
I don't wanna I don't I know I'm not
gonna believe what Paul wrote in Romans
until you show me God no God showed Paul
and Paul showed me and I've got to
accept it from Paul because that's how
God chose to convey the information
are you with me so far
okay so so God chose prophets to be
spokespersons for himself now here's
something that I think is especially
important who specifically is the one
speaking through the prophet
I want you to take your Bibles
to the Book of Revelation again chapter
12. now this is very important what we
look at here Revelation chapter 12. and
verse 17.
Revelation 12 and verse 17.
notice what the Bible says
the Dragon
was enraged with the woman and he went
to make war with the rest of her
offspring
who keep the Commandments of God
and have the testimony of Jesus Christ
of course I'm reading new King James and
the King James says the remnant of her
seed Etc
the dragon which is the devil went
against the woman which is God's Church
and he was enraged
over two things
Commandments
and what it calls the testimony of Jesus
the dragon was enraged at these things
incidentally if the dragon if the
devil's enraged about something do you
expect that that thing will get good PR
or bad PR
even in the church
he was enraged with these two things now
notice it says this this Remnant this
group has the testimony of Jesus Christ
now at Seventh-day Adventist we have
made it our practice to go to Revelation
chapter 19 and let the Bible interpret
itself so we go to Revelation 19 and
verse 10.
Revelation 19 and verse 10. now notice
what the scripture says
John is is is receiving this Vision the
Angel that's instructing him is there
and John says I fell at his feet to
worship Him
I want you to know the language very
carefully too I fell on his feet to
worship him but he said to me see that
you do not do that
I am your fellow servant
I'm your what
fellow servant and of your what
Brethren who have the testimony of Jesus
worship God for the testimony of Jesus
is the spirit of Prophecy
the testimony of Jesus is the spirit of
Prophecy or the gift of Prophecy now
we've said that as Adventists and here's
what the critics are saying today even
some in the Adventist Church testimony
of Jesus does not refer to well here
I'll read it to you from Dirk Anderson
who is who is a former Adventist who's
on one of these anti-avenous websites
listen to what he says internet critic
Dirk Anderson claims that throughout the
New Testament we find a pattern of the
testimony of Jesus referring to the
believer's personal witness about Jesus
Christ
okay so so so the his point is when
Adventists try to say the testimony of
Jesus that the remnant church is going
to have
points to the gift of Prophecy we're all
wrong all the testimony of Jesus really
has to do with is the personal
believer's testimony about what Jesus
has done in their life that's the claim
now what's interesting is I haven't
anybody here ever read the proclamation
Magazine see this Proclamation are you
familiar with this magazine I have I'm
going to talk about this a little bit
later now one of the guys behind this
anybody see this before this is an ant
this is a former Adventist group that's
trying to rescue Adventist out of the
Adventist Church and they target they
get our mailing list and then they
target us with their their Proclamation
magazine to help us to understand the
light of the true gospel element's a
false prophet Sanctuary isn't in heaven
and all this business okay and um
there's an article in one of these
written by a man named Dale ratslap
anybody heard that name before no rat's
laugh is one of these key guys Behind
These some of these anti-advinist
websites and uh ratsoff writes an
article a four-page article on this
issue of the testimony of Jesus
showing he's going to text after text
after text in the Bible to show that the
testimony of Jesus refers to the
believer's testimony about what Jesus
did in their life not to the gift of
Prophecy and in four pages and all the
texts he goes to there's one text he
doesn't go to and the reason he doesn't
go to it is because he can't go to it
because it tear apart his whole argument
and that's revelation 22.
and we go to Revelation 12 17 it says
the testimony of Jesus is the spirit of
Prophecy I'm sorry the remnant church
will have the Testament of Jesus we go
to Revelation 19 10. it says The
Testament of Jesus is the spirit of
Prophecy but I want you to notice
revelation 22 this just solidifies the
point
revelation 22 notice verse 8.
revelation 22 verse 8 this is almost a
perfect parallel it is a perfect
parallel it's just not exact language of
Revelation 20 or Revelation 19 10 rather
now I John saw and heard these things
and when I saw and heard I fell down to
worship before the feet of the Angel who
showed me these things
then he said to me what
see that you don't do that is this
ringing a bell
did we just read this in Revelation 19
10 yes or no yeah I mean it was right
there now notice notice the language
notice how he goes on for I he says
don't see that you don't do that for I
am your fellow what servant same thing
as he said before
and of your brethren what
the prophets
in in Revelation 19 10 he said I am of
your brethren who have the testimony of
Jesus
but in revelation 22 8 9 he doesn't say
I am of your brethren who have to
testimony about what Jesus did in their
life
he says I'm of your brethren the
prophets
because the Testament of Jesus is the
spirit of Prophecy or the gift that the
prophets have
are you following that you you see why
Dale Radcliffe didn't put that one in
his article
that one clears up the fact that when
the Bible speaks of the testimony of
Jesus is speaking of the gift of
Prophecy now testimony what is a
testimony
let me look at it let me have you go to
another text with me and we'll clarify
this first Peter 1.
first Peter
after Hebrews in the New Testament you
come to James then first Peter First
Peter chapter one and we're going to
verse 10.
and notice what the Bible says here
foreign
speaking of the Plan of Salvation as
taught through the Prophecies of Old
Testament scripture which was the only
Bible that Peter had by the way
of this salvation the prophets have
inquired and searched carefully who
prophesied of the grace that would come
to you in other words Daniel and Isaiah
and Jeremiah they they themselves
searched what it meant that God showed
them
they didn't have all the understanding
did Daniel understand everything God
showed him no I mean he had some of the
visions and he says I fainted and I was
sick for days but nobody understood the
vision
now if Daniel didn't understand
everything he wrote is it possible that
other prophets didn't understand
everything they wrote when they wrote
them
yes or no did that make them less true
no it doesn't matter if the prophet
figured God told Daniel at the end of
the book Daniel you go your way you go
your way your Prophet your prophecy will
have the right bearing at the right time
okay
at any rate so Peter tells us the
prophet searched about this salvation
you know they all prophesied about
Christ and his coming and in the
Salvation The Plan of Salvation and and
and so he says in verse 11 they were
searching what or what manner of time
notice the language here the spirit of
who
the spirit of Christ who was where
in
them
who's them
the prophets who was in the prophets
the spirit of who Christ was in them
okay
so they were searching what or what
manner of time the spirit of Christ who
was in them was indicating when he the
spirit of Christ did what
did he do
testified beforehand
the spirit of Christ himself was in the
prophets he was in Isaiah he was in
Jeremiah he was in Daniel testifying
beforehand about what was going to come
to pass about the ministry of Christ
when somebody testifies you could say
they're giving their what
they're what their testimony who was in
the prophets giving his testimony
the spirit of Christ or Jesus so if
Jesus was in the prophets giving his
testimony could you call the gift of
Prophecy the testimony of Jesus yes
and this is simply biblical if we take
the time to look through it that when we
when we so so here's the question who is
the one specifically now you know the
prophet is a spokesperson for God we saw
that in the Bible who specifically is
the one that's speaking to you and me
through the prophets according to
scripture
Jesus is
you follow that so when the prophet
speaks if it is a true prophet of God
it's the voice of who that I'm hearing
Jesus
are you with me so far
okay
now there are a lot of roles that the
prophet had in the scripture I mean I'll
share with you some we don't have time
to go I'm going to highlight one that I
think is the among the most important
but among other things the scripture
says that the
um prophets laid the foundation of
church in their teachings
that's Ephesians 2 20.
the prophets equipped the Saints for the
work of ministry we'll see that a little
bit that's in Ephesians 4 12. prophets
initiated and coordinated the missionary
work of the church acts 13 1-2 acts 16
6-10
profits provided proper boundaries and
guidelines for the church Proverbs 29
18. prophets warned of future
difficulties in the church acts 11 27-30
Acts 20 23 acts 21 4 and 10-14 if you
have questions afterwards you want some
of these texts you can ask me for them
but one of the most important roles of
the gift of Prophecy has been and is the
preserving of unity of belief among
Believers and preventing doctrinal
confusion especially in times of
controversy okay we're going to go to
Ephesians chapter 4
.
Matthew Mark Luke John acts Romans first
and second Corinthians Galatians
Ephesians Ephesians 4
and starting in verse 11.
now in Ephesians 4 Paul's talking about
the gifts of the Spirit not just the
gift of Prophecy
but all the spiritual gifts you'll see
that here verse 11 and he himself
speaking of Jesus gave some to be
Apostles some prophets some evangelists
some pastors and teachers
for the equipping of the Saints for the
work of ministry
for the edifying or the building up of
the body of Christ
notice verse 13 till we all come to the
what
Unity of the faith and we're going to
see that played out in some other verses
as well to the unit to a Oneness of
understanding and belief to the unity of
the faith this is not just unity in
general this is unity of the faith Unity
of belief a Oneness among God's people
okay
till we all come to the unity of the
faith and of the knowledge of the Son of
God to a perfect man or a mature man to
the measure of the stature of the
fullness of Christ why verse 14 so that
we should no longer be children tossed
to and fro and carried about with every
wind of What
doctrine by the trickery of men
in the cunning craftiness of deceitful
plotting
Paul says among other purposes for the
spiritual gifts one of the key purposes
is to bring us to a Unity of the faith
so that when all these different
doctrines what's doctrine mean
Doctrine means what
teaching teaching a doctor
is a teacher when you get your doctorate
you can now teach
technically a doctor medical doctor was
to teach you how not to get sick
you can think about that you ought to
know that here at Loma Linda okay so
you've got Doctrine is teaching
and the idea is that that that Paul says
that the gifts of the Spirit and all
these pastors teachers evangelists
Apostles prophets was given so that it
could bring us to a Oneness of teaching
so in all the different teachings
started coming around we wouldn't get
tossed through and fro to and fro and
sidetracked with different teachings
that we would be clear on what the right
path was
how many of you like to know that
something is right
versus I don't know if we can know
whether it's right or wrong does that
bother anybody besides me I mean there
are things in the Bible that are not as
plain as others there are times I've
asked the Lord for direction and it's
just not black and white has anybody
ever had this before you're wishing God
would write it in the clouds and the
clouds would form in and say do this or
do that you say Thank You Lord right or
the audible Audible Voice would come to
you or me and say you know Mark you've
been asking me here's the answer to your
question
anybody would anybody here like that
besides me I I would long for that
sometimes but the point is
that sometimes there are things that
aren't as clear and it's frustrating and
it's perplexing I like when things can
be clear
and as many
things in the Bible that may as there
are that may not be clear there are also
things in the Bible that are clear and
there are plain
and and there's a mindset today that we
can't really know what truth is you know
we're it's nobody you know I mean you've
got your brand and you've got your brand
and I guess we're all just okay listen
that's frustrating
God is Not That ambiguous and the
scripture is not that ambiguous there
are again I'll say it again there are
things in the scripture that are not
black and white but there are things in
the scripture that are black and white
and the reason for the spiritual gifts
according to the Apostle Paul was to
bring us to Unity on those black and
white things
now the difference between apostles
and teachers and evangelists
and um
Apostles prophets teachers evangelist
which one did I miss
between prophets and the others
is that God communicated directly to the
prophets
and then the prophets uh get the the
pastors and the apostles and the
teachers and the evangelists get their
Authority from what the prophets wrote
isn't that right look I'm not a prophet
or the son of a prophet as Amos says
this is my authority here
this is my only Authority as a minister
of the Gospel where did I get it
from the prophets right so so this idea
today that people give off well you know
I believe in the Bible but I don't know
about prophecy what are you talking
about the Bible is prophecy
if you don't believe in Prophecy you got
to get rid of most of your Bible
because you got it from Prophets
Moses the first five books of the Bible
where Moses get it from he saw it
because he was a prophet
amen
sorry
I was going off on a tangent here so I'm
going to focus on this Ephesians 4
according to Ephesians 4 and let me make
a point a little more plain one of the
roles of the spiritual gifts one of the
roles of prophets is to clarify
doctrinal positions
that's biblical
you know I didn't even bring up Ellen
White's name yet you hear what I'm
saying from a Biblical perspective the
role of the Prophet is to have something
to say on Doctrine
and that's a question today in the
church that well Ellen White if people
today say well I think Alan White's
writings were more pastoral in nature
they're more devotional in nature she
she just shouldn't have anything to do
with formation of Doctrine have you
heard that
how many have heard that okay what does
Paul say
does that fit with what we just read
Paul say no we're not going to just
leave it with Paul well we may we go to
we're going to go to something else that
Paul wrote here we're going to go to a
couple different things I want you to go
to the book of First Corinthians 4.
there's a couple other passages I want
to look at in our time this morning
First Corinthians chapter
one sorry I said four First Corinthians
chapter one
First Corinthians chapter one now
starting in verse 4 Paul is sharing with
uh sharing with the Corinthian Church
the church at Corinth and he says in
verse 4 I thank my God always concerning
you for the grace of God which was given
to you by Christ Jesus
that you were enriched in everything by
Him in all what
my Bible says all utterance and all
knowledge now follow along here this is
very important Paul's writing to the
church in Corinth and he says God has
given you a special gift Corinth he's
given you understanding
he's enriched you in all utterance that
is what
utterance speech it says in the King
James doesn't say speech in the King
James What You Preach what you teach
right Corinthians God has enriched you
in what you preach and teach
right in all utterance and in all what
knowledge now this is knowledge of
spiritual things he says Church in
Corinth God has blessed you with in the
preaching and teaching of Truth and in
the knowledge of Truth
are you with me so far notice what it
goes on to say verse 6.
even as the testimony of Christ was
confirmed in you
testimony of Christ now we know what
that is we just looked at it in several
passages testimony of Christ testimony
of Jesus is what
now I want you I was looking in in uh
just some different translations here
let me let me find where I am here uh
the testimony now if you're reading in
The New American Standard Bible says the
testimony concerning Christ
if you read in the NIV it says our
testimony about Christ was confirmed in
you see the testimony about Jesus that's
not what it's saying
it says you've been enriched in your
knowledge because of the Testament in in
let me go on here nesb testimony
concerning Christ the NIV says our
testimony about Christ the ESV says the
testimony about Christ but this isn't
Paul's point you can say well how do you
know look at the next verse
he says even as the testimony of Christ
is confirmed in you so that you come
short in what
no gift in all of these versions that I
spoke of allow for the fact in fact they
even say so you come short you don't
lack in any spiritual gift
what spiritual gift is the testimony of
Christ
the gift of Prophecy
and what the Apostle Paul is saying here
is that
even as you have responded to the
prophetic gift in your midst God has
enriched your understanding of Truth and
your preaching of truths
Seventh-day Adventist what we understand
about truth is phenomenal and we don't
we we we don't even realize it
most Seventh-Day Adventists have more of
an understanding of God his
righteousness his character than most
other Christians now I'm not trying to
be you know somebody would say oh how
can you say that because I work with
other Christians on a regular basis and
when they start to hear what we teach
they're like I've never heard this in my
whole life
I just baptized a 17 71 year old woman
who came to a series of meetings I did
this woman had been in churches her
whole life from this church this church
this church this church came to that
meeting and says I've never learned this
much in my whole life
I do a prison ministry in in Coldwater
Michigan and the prisoners come from the
other groups the Baptist group the
Methodist group Etc they come to our
group you want to know why
I say are you guys having us they say no
I said why are you coming here they say
because all the other groups get up and
they tell stories and nobody ever gets
into the Bible and you guys open the
Bible and preach it and I'm learning
more here than I've learned my whole
life
so I'm not trying to put down anybody
else you understand what I'm saying
I'm simply saying that our understanding
of Truth
is because of the gift of Prophecy
and and and it's almost the height of it
it's it's like a person who wants to
glory in the beauty of their own created
being but deny the Creator
it's like that when Seventh-Day
Adventists wanted glory in the truth
that they know about God's character but
they deny the source
the gift of Prophecy among us this is
what Paul says to this church he says
listen the reason you have such an
understanding is because you've
responded to God's Gift among you and
notice what he goes on to say then
so that you come short in no gift and
then he goes on in verse 10 in this
context and says now I plead with you
Brethren by the name of our Lord Jesus
Christ that you all won
speak the same things and that there be
what no divisions among you but that you
be what perfectly joined together in the
what
same mind and the same judgment is that
powerful or what
I have Adventists tell me today I don't
know that we're ever going to see eye to
eye
that's because we look at Humanity
God is able to bring Oneness in his
church and that doesn't mean we're all
going to like blue you understand you
might like green and I may like blue
that's okay but we need to have a
Oneness of understanding on God's truth
where are we going to get it
God has given the spiritual gifts to
guide us into Unity the unity of the
faith that's the role of them
as far as the formation of Doctrine
let's go a little bit more specific
we're going to go to the book of Acts
Acts chapter 15 we're going to see this
at work in the church in the early
Christian Church
Matthew Mark Luke John Acts 15.
and we'll do this briefly
let me give you the run-in on Acts 15.
in the early Christian Church there
became there came a controversy in fact
I'll read it to you there in the first
few verses of Acts 15 it says and
certain men came down from Judea and
taught the Brethren unless you are
circumcised according to the custom of
Moses you cannot be saved
therefore when Paul and Barnabas had no
small dissension I love the way Luke
writes we were out on the ocean and
there was no small storm
it was a big storm there was no small
dissension
and dispute among them they determined
that Paul and Barnabas and certain
others should go up to Jerusalem to the
apostles and Elders about this question
and goes on to say they went back and
verse 5 but some of the sect of the
Pharisees who believed rose up saying it
is necessary to circumcise the new
Believers and to command them to keep
the law of Moses
so you have this controversy over
circumcision in the early church and
what happens is they need some
resolution what are we going to do
notice something interesting about this
passage
Paul and Barnabas disagrees with the
others he didn't say look you guys just
go start your branch church we'll start
our Branch Church and we'll just do it
our own way
they had a desire
to be at one
so much so they took a trip they didn't
just hop in the car and take a nice
smooth cruise down to Jerusalem this was
a journey but it was so important to
them to have a Oneness with the World
Church they went down to Jerusalem and
they settled the map
they wanted to go down and find out what
position are we going to take on this
now they get down to Jerusalem and
you've probably read this before Acts
chapter 15. I'm going to jump ahead
I want you to notice something that
happens here
yeah verse six we're not jumping ahead
we're going in verse six now when now
the apostles and Elders came together to
consider this matter and when there had
been much dispute Peter rose up and said
to them men and Brethren you know that a
good while ago God chose Among Us that
by my mouth the Gentiles should hear the
word of the gospel and believe
now notice what Peter says Brethren he
speaks to everybody assembled there you
know that God chose out of all of us to
send me to the Gentiles where in the
scripture do we find record of that
moving go to Acts chapter what 21 22 and
the Apostle Paul shares his experience
and he says God said go far hence unto
the Gentiles I'm going to send you but
where did God in the scripture send
Peter to the Gentiles
come on somebody knows
Acts chapter 10.
Acts chapter 10. now I went through
several non-advinist commentaries and
they're all agreed upon this that this
reference is pointing back to Acts
chapter 10. and the experience of
Cornelius in the house of Cornelius
okay
now let me ask you this question those
of you who read Acts chapter 10 how did
God communicate to Peter that he was to
go to the Gentiles
through a vision
now follow along there's a doctrinal
dispute everybody's reading the
scripture there are scriptures in the
Bible in the book of Exodus it said if
anybody's going to come among you and be
a part of you they have to be
circumcised
that's where the Pharisees who believed
that's what they were holding to they
said okay well this is what the
scripture says they need to be
circumcised and and we read the
scripture this way but the apostles are
saying no no no no no that the the the
this this is not our understanding of
what the Lord's trying to direct us to
they were all reading the same Bible but
they were coming up with different
conclusions they came to Jerusalem and
as they shared what they'd been studying
Peter gets up and first point he makes
is God showed me in vision
that I was to take the gospel to the
Gentiles and not circumcised
are you following me
okay I'm not making this stuff up we get
it right out of the Bible Peter gets up
and cites vision
as the clarifying point for the teaching
so notice how James handles it Peter
goes on he's he he shares his his how
God chose among me and then he goes on
and explains the experience a little bit
and then verse 12 says in all the
multitude kept silence and listened to
Paul and Barnabas or rather Barnabas and
Paul declaring how many miracles and
wonders God had worked through them so
first you have Peter's vision that he
gets up and tells about and then his
experience and then you got Paul and
Barnabas get up and they try to confirm
what Peter says by the experience that
they've had now notice what James does
it's not settled yet
the Bible says in the next verse verse
13 after they had become silent James
answered saying men and Brethren listen
to me
Simon Peter has declared how God at
first visited the Gentiles to take out
of them of people by his name and with
this the words of the prophets what
agree
as it is written Etc so notice how the
process worked
doctrinal controversy they've been
studying the Bible the Bible's the
foundation for their belief but they
come to a to an impasse which position
do we take Peter gets up and says God
showed me thus and so Envision Paul and
Barnabas get up and say listen this was
our experience it conf it confirms
Peter's vision and then James says well
your experience is great but what we
need to do to confirm Peter's vision is
go to the scripture and we go to the
scripture and the scripture confirms the
vision of Peter and we take it now with
all of these things together that
Peter's vision is a decisive factor in
our solving this doctrinal dispute and
they adopt the policy that the Gentile
Believers didn't need to be circumcised
question did the vision have anything to
do with the formation of Doctrine in the
Bible
yes it did you can't go anywhere around
that and and does that fit with what
Paul said in Ephesians chapter 4 about
the spiritual gifts bringing us to the
unity of the faith does it fit with what
Paul said in First Corinthians chapter 1
about us having the same mind and same
judgment as we've been enriched with the
spiritual gifts
yes so it would be totally unbiblical
for Adventists to take the position that
Ellen White can't have a position in
solving doctrinal controversy in the
church
unless it can be proven she's a false
prophet if she's a prophet of God and as
goes for any prophet of God the role one
of the roles of the Prophet is to bring
Clarity on doctrinal issues
are you with me on that
so I'm going to close just a couple
comments here I know we're going a
little bit past I want to share with you
just a couple comments first of all from
Ellen White herself describing the
experience similar to what we just read
in Acts in the early Advent uh movement
in the gospel workers page 302 she says
we are to be established in the faith in
the light of the truth given us in our
early experience
at that time early experience of the
Avenue we're trying to hammer out our
doctrines at that time one error after
another pressed in upon us
ministers and doctors of theology
brought in new doctrines
we would search the scriptures which
with much prayer so that first place
they went is what does the Bible say we
would search the scriptures with much
prayer
and the Holy Spirit would bring the
truth to our minds sometimes whole
nights would be devoted to searching the
scriptures now I'm just going to have to
say something here and at the risk of
being offensive I'm going to say it
um
few of us spend a couple hours let alone
a whole night or entire night's plural
searching the scriptures for truth and
yet we're so confident that we have an
understanding more than Ellen White had
an understanding or the early Adventist
Pioneers I think that's I I
that's an insult to say the least
in other words
we need to be less
self-confident and more diligent as
students of the scripture these people
spent entire nights in searching the
scripture and then she goes on to say
uh earnestly asking God for guidance the
power of God would come upon me
and I was enabled clearly to Define what
is truth
and what is error
does that fit with Acts chapter 15 what
we just read that's what happened with
Peter that's how Ellen White says her
gift worked just in perfect accordance
with what the Bible says now if people
have issue with that the issue is not
with Ellen White's with scripture
we if we want to know how prophecy and
the gift of Prophecy works we it's not
up to us to to create that or to
manufacture that the Bible tells us how
it works
it's up to us to decide whether we want
to follow the scripture
and brothers and sisters this is how God
established the faith amongst us as a
people
God in our day wants us to be United as
a people
and God has given us the guiding gift of
Prophecy to do that uniting along with
the other gifts you understand what I'm
saying here
the question that we need to ask
ourselves this morning
and being totally honest with ourselves
is do we really want to be United as
Seventh-Day Adventists is it your desire
this morning to be United as a body of
Believers that have the same
understanding of biblical truth is that
your desire
is it your desire even at the expense of
maybe having to give up your own
cherished viewpoint
you didn't answer that one as fast
it goes for me too brothers and sisters
listen if is it our desire I want to
leave it at that this morning we're
going to talk this afternoon a little
bit more about the gift of Prophecy but
we have to be honest with our own hearts
and maybe you can't even answer it right
now but I want you to ask yourself that
question is it my desire
to have a Unity among us as a people
even at the cost of me having to change
my cherished opinions
am I willing to allow God to have his
say in the matter
okay you may say well you know okay but
I still have issues with Illinois go
ahead and have issues with Ellen White
if you do
I'm not even bringing Ellen White into
this just yet
I'm just taking from what we what we
looked at in the scripture and allowing
the prophetic gift as God has given it
where you do accept it to be the guide
are you willing to do that is that your
desire this morning
raise your hands with me if that's your
desire this morning and let's pray
together bow your heads with me Heavenly
Father
we are at a crucial time in this Earth's
history and Lord now more than ever we
need a clear and direct path to follow
we need Oneness amongst us father we
can't go forward and finish this Mission
when we can't even agree
and I pray father that you would help us
to allow the gift of Prophecy to have
its proper place Among Us
Lord not just in the writings of Ellen
White there are many of us who don't
allow the writings of scripture to have
their proper place
oh Father you know the hearts of your
people here this morning
father I want Unity
even at the cost of me having to see
things differently I want Unity amongst
us as a people
because there's power in that Unity
and father I pray
as you've seen the raised hands here
this morning as you know the hearts of
each one here that you would give us
that Unity bring us to the unity of the
faith
and the knowledge of Christ
to Christian maturity to the measure of
the stature of the fullness of Jesus
that his character may be seen in US
this is our prayer this morning in the
name of Jesus and for his sake amen